good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight has there been look back
a single 24-hour period since Joe Biden
became the president when you haven't
been horrified by something you saw on
the news probably not the Cascade of
absurdities has been Relentless it's
like nothing any American has ever seen
and today we're sad to say was
especially depressing inflation hit
another record high and that's according
to the cooked government statistics our
leaders have devised to hide inflation
but it turns out there's no hiding the
price of meat and gas the value of the
dollar has dropped off a cliff even as
the value of the Russian Ruble is rising
so ponder that for a moment and chuckle
bitterly to yourself
and then in New York City this morning
16 people were shot on the subway in
Brooklyn by some lunatic wearing a
hoodie
and yet somehow none of the many
surveillance cameras in the subway
station happen to be working at the time
so the guy got away
we do know he was not a white
supremacist who were betting the media
are not going to dwell on this there's
nothing to gain from covering this
particular atrocity just another mass
shooting in a big city
it's also sad
but Mayhem and economic decline are not
for once what we are opening the show
with tonight no we have genuinely good
news and here it is it looks possible
that Elon Musk will seize control of
Twitter and end censorship on that
platform now why should you care about
that it's like a tech story right who
cares about social media here's why you
should care because if that were to
happen we could see a return of free
speech to the United States and nothing
should give you more hope than that
possibility a free Twitter would mean an
open debate about ideas on the single
most important incubator of elite
opinion in the world
it would mean a return to free and fair
elections in the United States a system
in which both sides are allowed to make
their case to the public and the public
can decide it's called democracy
and above all a free Twitter would mean
a direct challenge to the people in
charge of our country's institutions
many of whom are incompetent for the
first time in years we will be able to
talk honestly about our leaders we'll be
able to have the kind of conversations
that make democracy possible we can't
have those conversations now and there's
a reason for it
the point of censorship is never to
Shield the weak no matter what Barack
Obama may tell you the point of
censorship always and everywhere is to
protect entrenched power that's why it's
the powerful who impose censorship for
their own benefit and that's exactly why
illegitimate regimes fight so hard to
control information through censorship
that's their main concern why are they
so focused on that that's why
somehow the right does not seem to
understand this the left definitely
understands it watch this MSNBC anchor
appear to realize in real time what it
would mean if the Democratic party's
donor base ever lost control of an
influential social media platform
and the bigger question on everyone's
mind now will musk's new found Twitter
power mean Trump will be back on the
platform
and on that possibly nightmare inducing
note I wish you a good night
it would be a nightmare she tells us if
a democratically elected president were
allowed to speak in public and in some
ways she's right shattering its Monopoly
on speech could break the Democratic
party even in MSNBC anchor understands
that why are they so determined to keep
you from talking because they know
you're talking is the threat to their
power allowing the free exchange of
ideas in America's Public Square is far
more important than any single election
result
and if you don't believe it consider
what we've just seen over the past two
years you can elect Donald Trump if you
want go ahead and do it but the
Democratic party can still silence
Donald Trump at will
so what does that tell you who's more
powerful voters or the social media
companies that control what voters know
it's not even close
republicans in Congress pretend not to
understand this maybe they really are
that stupid possible doesn't matter
because either way they will never fix
it ever they've had a chance they passed
even Jack Dorsey who created Twitter
could not end censorship on Twitter and
so in the end Jack Dorsey fled his own
company when it became a Frankenstein
monster that made America more
hierarchical rather than less a company
that served the powerful at the expense
of everyone else that was the opposite
of the intended effect so he just left
he had no choice
Elon Musk virtually alone in the entire
technology industry appears to
understand what exactly is happening
here here's musk in 2018 appearing on 60
Minutes acknowledging that in a world of
corporate media Twitter can act as an
equalizer watch
you tweet a lot I use my tweets to
express myself
some people use their hair I use Twitter
well but you use your tweeting to to
kind of get back at critics yeah you
kind of have little Wars with the Press
Twitter is a war zone if somebody's
going to jump in the war zone
it's like okay you're in the arena let's
go okay who does that sound like
I don't know who's this sound like it
sounds like a guy who lives at the White
House oh that guy yeah sure
he's very good at Twitter
is a war zone now that tape is from
three and a half years ago Twitter is no
longer a war zone there's only one Army
on the field Donald Trump has been
banned for Twitter despite the fact he
may run in the next presidential race
he's an active politician with millions
of people who would support him he's
been banned Charlie Kirk had a huge
following on Twitter he's been suspended
too so is the Babylon B and for that
matter this show has been suspended
questioning a prevailing storyline
is the crime do that and you're gone it
doesn't matter if you're factually right
we were factually right doesn't matter
challenge power and you are censored
instantly
now it's hard to believe that the
world's richest man is the only person
who could fix this you'd like to think
our Democratic systems could fix it but
clearly they can't so Elon Musk seems to
be our last hope and tonight there are
signs that Elon Musk plans to do
something big with Twitter
buying nine percent of the company was
clearly more than an investment he
doesn't need the money last week after
musk became Twitter's single biggest
shareholder Twitter's management
announced that he would join their board
of directors the seat would come with
two major restrictions first musk would
be barred from owning more than 15
percent of Twitter stock he would not be
allowed to control the company
second as a board member Elon Musk would
have a fiduciary duty to shareholders
and in real terms that means he could
not reveal Twitter's algorithms he
couldn't tell the public what they are
now those algorithms are used to censor
and suppress effective critics of the
bid Administration very often without
their knowledge is done in secret you
can't fight back you don't even know
what's happening
so he could not challenge that if he
took a board seat but this weekend musk
abruptly pulled out of the deal and that
means he's free to buy more shares of
Twitter in fact to control it
on Sunday night Twitter's Pro censorship
CEO Prague Agarwal told Twitter
employees to brace for musk's attempt at
a hostile takeover he also strongly
implied that Twitter
will not submit unless forced quote
there will be distractions ahead but our
goals and priorities remain unchanged
so you have to ask yourself how exactly
would Twitter which is a public company
fight off a hostile takeover from the
richest guy in the world and already you
can see the strategy to keep Elon Musk
at Bay
first Twitter is enlisting the help of
corporate media now corporate media
stands to lose at least as much as the
Democratic party will lose if Twitter is
liberated competition is terrible for
the mediocre and the illegitimate so
MSNBC understands this intuitively even
the AirHeads read the scripts on the air
and so they were the first to answer the
call what did they do you know exactly
what they did they did what they always
do they called Elon Musk a racist watch
fear not right Wingers another bro
fascist is waiting in the wings to
defend your right to spew bile online in
the name of free speech and that is
coming up next He is building in Tesla
uh documentedly racist company that
perhaps reminds him gives him nostalgic
memories of apartheid South Africa where
he grew up he's more than that an
embodiment of what I would say is
Twitter's biggest strategic problem
which is a hostile cruel dangerous
online environment especially for women
especially for people of color women of
color in particular
we can bore you with a rebuttal to the
ludicrous explanation you just heard but
it's not necessary if you have an IQ
above room temperature you laugh at it
that's the lowest brow propaganda
possible it's all MSNBC it's capable
he's a racist ignore him
but at the Washington Post they served
up something slightly different a little
more stealthy they Enlisted the former
CEO of Reddit an activist mediocrity
called Ellen Powell who couldn't manage
to actually run Reddit to write an op-ed
with this title quote Elon musk's vision
of free speech will be bad for Twitter
and then the piece contained this line
now this line doesn't so much reveal a
lack of self-awareness as it does commit
murder against the entire concept
they're trying to support and here's
what it is quote musk's appointment to
Twitter's board shows that we need
regulation on social media platforms to
prevent rich people from controlling our
channels of communication
now once again this ran in the
Washington Post a paper that apparently
unbeknownst to the editors who worked
there is owned by billionaire oligarch
Jeff Bezos China's biggest retailer and
used as his personal platform to Lobby
the federal government and settle scores
so Jeff Bezos can own the only news
Gathering operation in your nation's
capital and use it for business and
ideological ends but the idea of letting
average people say what they want on
Twitter is a threat to democracy
and if you think that's hilarious you
should read the piece in the guardian it
was written by former labor secretary
Robert Reich well stalinist quote Elon
musk's vision for the internet is
dangerous nonsense and the sub subhead
read this way quote musk has long
advocated for a Libertarian vision of an
uncontrolled internet that's also the
dream of every dictator strong man and
demagogue
right so what dictators strong men and
demagogues want is the people over whom
they rule to say whatever they want and
to challenge their power that's kind of
the way dictatorships work isn't that
right Robert the funny thing is Robert
Reich is a lifelong leftist now pushing
80. you can imagine the Robert Reich of
say 1970 when he was a little College ad
Advocate would be a little bit surprised
to see the Robert Reich of nearly 80
calling for a total Crackdown on the
opinions of ordinary people but you know
people get power and they change
but that doesn't make any sense as an
argument you can see why they stick to
calling Elon Musk a racist on cable news
they just stick to the same old script
and that's what they're doing at CNN of
course watch
I think in some ways it's a good thing
that Elon is out there tweeting livening
up Twitter making it more entertaining
as Kara said he's a funny guy but there
are serious questions behind that what
what happens next does he push for a
full acquisition we don't know yeah and
maybe he's just in there for the walls
but some of the means he posts on
Twitter anti-trans memes anti-covet
vaccine memes there's a reason to be
skeptical I think here
he has questions about the mandate
mandatory vaccine crush him
no one's went over by this it's absurd
so clearly that propaganda strategy will
not win open minds to the side of
censorship in fact it's impossible to
win open minds to the side of censorship
because the idea is repugnant to any
free spirit
so there's other tools that Twitter's
going to have to use to stop a hostile
takeover on behalf of free speech so for
example it's virtually certain that
Twitter's on the phone now with
corporate lawyers in New York finding
ways to use what's known as a poison
pill strategy to minimize Elon musk's
ownership stake as much as it possibly
can one option and this would be really
interesting is to give Twitter
shareholders the ability to buy many
more shares at a discount to dilute
musk's control over the company but that
strategy is not guaranteed to work musk
himself has a ton of options aside from
buying all the shares he wants for
example you might think of this Elon
Musk could enlist the public the
pro-free speech public in his hostile
takeover of Twitter so anyone who is
against censorship could buy Twitter
stock and then pledge his or her proxy
votes to Elon Musk and that would give
him control of the company and the
company would be free that would also be
the single most revolutionary event ever
to take place in the history of Finance
it'd be pretty thrilling to watch and it
might work maybe we'll try it
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight